neben wäre der perfekte stoff für einen
kinofilm aus kind musste er vor den
nazis fliehen obwohl er christlich
erzogen wurde in seiner neuen heimat
nordamerika riet ihm albert einstein ein
freund der familie zum medizinstudium
doch ihn interessierte das weltgeschehen
oder gehörte bald zu den wichtigsten
historikern unserer zeit sein
forschungsgebiet die eigene doppelte
heimat deutschland und amerika heute ist
er hier
fritz stern herzlich willkommen danke
ihnen vielmals freude hier zu sein
schön gegenwärtig haben wir in europa
die größte flüchtlingskatastrophe seit
dem zweiten weltkrieg bilder wie diese
hier sind omnipräsent gehen durch die
ganze welt ja was machen diese bilder
mit ihnen fritz stern
sie machen mich ungeheuer besorgt
traurig und voller fragen was kann man
da was kann man machen das ist besser
geht
wo ist die eu ja wo ist europa heute so
kann es nicht weitergehen
wie könnte es weitergehen ja das ist es
das ist eine große frage die ich sage
auch nicht so leicht beantworten kann
es ist irgendwie zu zumindestens
verschiedenen lösungen kommen und das
muss man ganz europa glaub ich
organisiert werden
denn die flüchtlinge wollen nach europa
zum großen teil anscheinend auf
deutschland aber es ist eine europäische
herausforderung von von ungeheurer
spannungsfeld und gleichzeitig sind die
bilder auf der einen seite für uns sagen
wir mal sofort dass man sorge hat
mitleid hat und so für andere ist das
natürlich auch wie soll ich sagen
an eine förderung der ins gewissen hier
kommen alle diese leute zu uns wir haben
hier und sie wissen ich meine die
meisten menschen wissen nicht dass man
in einem wohlhabenden paradies lebt
sozusagen
und man muss sich gewöhnen wie gesagt
muss sich anstrengen
ich glaube das hat auch die
bundeskanzlerin merkel das wort benutzt
weil ich kann mich täuschen
jedenfalls ist es eine anstrengung mit
dieser herausforderung nicht fertig zu
werden aber irgendwie sie in besserer
form zu bringen
sie leben in den usa in new york ja wie
reagiert man in den usa auf die
situation in europa ich bin jetzt seit
einem monat nicht mehr da ungefähr aber
kann mir vorstellen dass man es mit
bekommt sozusagen aber das sagen auf
distanz und dass einige beobachter und
kommentator sich über europa klagen
wurden die europäischen tun nicht genug
und so weiter auf der anderen seite ist
es bei uns auch ein problem also der
einwanderung und so weiter aber nicht in
demselben ausmaß wie bei ihnen wie hier
in europa ist die zuweilen stimmen in
europa die sagen auch die usa wäre in
der pflicht die ganze destabilisierung
von syrien dem ganzen gebiet rund um
syrien sei auch ein stück weit die
verantwortung der usa und die usa
müssten mehr tun werden solche thesen
diskutiert in den usa wie gesagt ich
glaube ja dass er diskutiert werden
ich bin auch ziemlich sicher dass es
innerhalb der regierung also innerhalb
obamas präsidentschaft darüber
gesprochen und sorgen gemacht und
möglicherweise auch schon pläne
und ich gebe ohne weiteres möglich recht
geben dass die vereinten staaten auch
das sagen
mit agieren würden denn zum teil den
ferien nicht ganz unschuldig an der
ganzen unruhe
sie haben selber eine flüchtlings
geschichte fritz stern sie sind mit
zwölf jahren von breslau geflohen vor
dem nazi-regime
wie blickt man mit ihrer geschichte auf
flüchtlinge nur wie gesagt mit mit
großer mit großem mitleid und
verständnis
auf der anderen seite ist wahrscheinlich
ein fundamentaler unterschied in dem
sinne dass ich wie sie sagten glaube ich
1938 mit zwölf jahren aus gewandelt wie
man das damals nannte von deutschland
aber der plan auszuwandern ich stolpere
immer über dieses wort falls mitwandern
selber nichts zu tun hat mit mit
emigrieren mit auswandern weil meine
eltern und daher auch ich schon seit
1933 beschäftigt also mit dem antritt
von von adolf hitler an die macht
er war ziemlich klar dass man das land
verlassen sollte und würde und das ist
ich muss bei aller tiefe man erkenne
meine eltern auch sagen die haben das
sofort verstanden und auch versucht der
erste versuch war in frankreich
mein vater dem hotel in paris gearbeitet
als mediziner aber eine länge also eine
wirkliche aufenthaltserlaubnis bekommen
antworten ich kann mit mit problemen wie
diese armen menschen kann ich mich habe
ich ein gewisses verständnis
ich sag bloß ich hatte es besser in dem
sinne dass ich vorbereitet war und ich
glaube nicht dass die kinder aus syrien
oder irak oder wo auch immer eine art
vorbereitung hatten oder das auch nur
eltern die ihnen wirklich helfen konnten
und so dass schon ein unterschied
es war sozusagen eine politische
bedrohung sie wussten dass sie am leib
und leben bedroht werden könnten aber
ihr haus war sozusagen noch nicht
zerstört was sie gingen
ist in keiner weise stört mein vater
alleine immer noch eine sehr angesehene
praxis als als internist als ja aber es
war ganz klar das ist das ist wie soll
ich sagen es war
man lebt halt mann lebte in unfreiheit
und ich hatte auch nur einen wunsch raus
und hatte sogar muss ich sagen meinen
eigenen plan zum weggehen habe ich
geschieden und freunden in der tschechei
also so genannten zu dessen deutsch aber
sozialdemokraten dass ich ohne meine
eltern wenn meine eltern mich fertig
sind und ich bin noch nicht das visum
für die vereinigten staaten hatten dass
ich zu ihnen ziehen wollen ertrag in die
französischen schule gehen würde und so
weiter die idee war richtig die
ausführung für schrecklich gewesen
und gott sei dank ist mir das erspart
geblieben sie schreiben in ihrem buch
fritz stern für deutschland und ein
leben ihre erinnerungen da das schreiben
sie sehr detailliert auch darüber dass
sie eben religiös eigentlich gezogen
worden sind also christlich erzogen
worden sind sie an weihnachten gefeiert
sagt nikolaus gefeiert alle diese
feiertage ihre eigene schwester wurde
noch 19 35 konsumiert ja und trotzdem
mit den nürnberger gesetzen haftet den
plötzlich das etikett nicht aaa wichtig
richtig wie war das für sie als kind
plötzlich mit so einer fremd
zuschreibung einer identität
konfrontiert zu werden
ich hatte gar keine ahnung muss sagen
also das war 33
ich habe irgendwie an glaube ich eine
freche bemerkung zu meiner älteren
schwester gemacht 33 und wurde vom vater
in seinem in seinem arbeitszimmer
der doktor zimmer gerufen so zu sagen
und da hat er mir klargemacht dass
jüdische abstammung wehren dass er soll
den neuen gesetzen als nicht zu
verstehen ist ich kann mir nicht denken
dass ich nicht aber damals verstanden
habe aber das dass wir irgendwie
ausgegrenzt worden und daher in einer
gewissen weise gefährdet das habe ich
glaube ich sofort verstanden respektiere
ich wusste das schon dass hitler eine
ganz große gefahr
aber das war mir klar als ich von der
schule nach hause ging
30 19 33 er war ein echter blatt zu
kaufen was weiß ich für fünf wenn ich
reiße ganz hitler reichskanzler geworden
sie habe ich gekauft und mein vater
überreicht wusste ganz genau dass es
sehr schlimme nachricht also ich war das
keine kündigte kleiner begeht so weit
ich war so seien in dem sinne schon
politisch etwas vorbereitet sie
beschreiben in ihrem buch auch dass sie
gehänselt wurden in der schule
es gab zum teil auch hat man sie das
nicht geschlagen oder oder gemobbt würde
man heute sagen
an einem gewissen punkt haben sie sich
gewehrt ja und sie schreiben ihr vater
hat ihnen dafür ein geschenk gegeben sie
schreiben auch nicht welches geschenk
weil das habe ich vergessen haben das
habe ich wirklich vergessen habe ich
weiß ganz genau dass er war stolz ja und
kam mir irgendwas geschenk
möglicherweise dann etwas für eine reise
wenn wir wieder ins ausland ging das war
einmal im jahr das man ja manchmal sogar
etwas mehr als elfter dass er mir damals
irgendwie was besonders zukommen lässt
man kriegt den eindruck wenn man dieses
buch liest dass sie ein inniges
verhältnis auch zu ihren eltern hat sich
ihre mutter war später auch montessori
lehrerin auch sie hat immer gearbeitet
der vater eben arzt aus einer
ärztefamilie und wenn man diese
geschichte liest dann stellt man sich
vor ihr vater war im ersten weltkrieg
offizier ihr habt eine hohe auszeichnung
erhalten für seine dienste war ein sehr
angesehener arzt und dann kommen diese
gesetze nicht aber es beginnt zu
bröckeln man kriegt den eindruck die
gesellschaft will diesen arzt nicht mehr
passieren vater gebrochen noch nicht
gebrochen würde ich sagen
müssen sie hatte ein schweres leben hat
seine eigenen eltern kurz vor dem ersten
weltkrieg verloren war dann vier jahre
lang im krieg und hat dann ist aus dem
krieg zurück gekommen politisch geschult
mit dem starken gefühl dass die deutsche
deutsche führung sagen wir mal vor dem
ersten weltkrieg sehr schlecht war
verantwortungslos und so weiter und
wurde in einem gewissen sinne ein ganz
klein wenig radikalisiert durch den
durch den krieg und durch seine
nachsicht durch sein verständnis der
vergangenheit der eigenen deutschen
vergangenheit von nutzern kürzen und war
dann selbstverständlich an
wie soll ich sagen einen antrag bei
bürger der weimarer republik und glaube
hat auch ich weiß nicht glaubt nicht
sofort aber dann sehr schnell
sozialdemokraten gewählt und aber ich
gleichzeitig möchte ich sagen auch in
der nazizeit noch hatte er eine rege
praxis auch mit vielen sogenannten
arischen patienten
ich meine diese ganze ausdruck ist mir
immer noch widerlich deswegen habe ich
gesagt so genannt und aber jahr für jahr
immer immer schlimmere ich kann nur
wiederholen dass gott seine eltern das
sehr schnell erkannt haben und versucht
haben gesagt raus zu gehen
sie sind dann via rotterdam nach new
york gekommen und sie beschreiben auch
wie sie vom moment dann sie angekommen
sind in den usa gewusst haben sie sind
in sicherheit
das hat mich insofern gerührt dass ich
gedacht habe ich bin in sicherheit
geboren ich bin in sicherheit
aufgewachsen
ich weiß nicht was es heißt an leib und
leben bedroht zu sein was was heißt das
für einen jungen menschen in ein land zu
kommen und zu wissen jetzt bin ich in
sicherheit
erst möchte ich ihnen gratulieren dass
in sicherheit aufgewachsen sind also ich
habe nichts dazu getan
doch sehr haben wir jetzt das
bewusstsein davon dass wir schon sehr
wichtig ich meine es gibt es sicher
viele wenn ich das sagen darf
schweizerinnen und schweizer die nicht
dieses bewusstsein haben das was
besonderes
darin liegt dass man sicherheit aufwärts
ich hatte nicht das glück auf zu wachsen
und daher auch keine besonders enge
beziehung zu meinen eltern wie ich schon
sagte ich ganz ganz kurz nur wenn sie
sagten meine mutter war montessori das
große das größte event in der familie im
jahre 1935 war eine einladung für meine
mutter nach bern und dem kam zurück mit
dem berner bär und das wurde alles
gefallen ich wurde eingeladen um ihre
eigenen ideen die hand für sich etwas
anders waren von der firma untersagt zu
entwickeln zu einem berner kongress der
pädagogik und deswegen wie gesagt unter
anderem also auch die schweiz seien ein
ganz besonders wichtiger punkt für uns
immer gewesen
ja absolut jetzt wollten sie erzählen
wie es für sie war dann in freiheit
anzukommen
ja das ist gar nicht so leicht zu sagen
ich meine ich konnte kein wort englisch
das erste wort glaube ich dass ich
gelernt habe war
sorry nicht zu entschuldigen aber es ja
auch tief blicken lässt dass das dass er
okay ich wie gesagt ich konnte konnte
kein englisch meine eltern hat deren
englisch war auch nicht so gut waren so
bürgerlich aufgewachsen aber auf
französisch und nicht auf englisch
damals zu den zeiten war das die erste
fremdsprache
also musste ich mich eigentlich erst mal
befassen mit massig ging gleich sehr
schnell in die
kommunale schule und da wurde ich sehr
nett aufgenommen von den anderen kindern
sozusagen und hab natürlich sprache
gelernt
ich fühlte mich irgendwie befreit ich
wüsste ich möchte es ihnen besser
gesehen
sorgenfrei oder sagen wir mal so die
sorgen waren ausgetauscht alte sorgen
was passiert wenn ihn einmal wurde ich
auf der straße von zwei nazis angehalten
weil ich was falsch gemacht haben so das
ist jetzt vorbei und ich weiß auch dass
ich das erste mal als ich mich in da wo
wir steht dann eine wohnung hatten nach
zwei wochen im hotel oder eine woche im
hotel ich mich an ein polizist gewandt
habe
der gedanke dass man sich an einem
polizisten wenden kann
in der annahme dass er freundlich ist
das war eben eine völlig neue erfahrung
und wird dessen wir euch bewusst
das ist vielleicht dieses dieses
bewusstsein der sicherheit ja
tatsächlich dazu dass ihnen zu schützen
absolut
das einzige was ich ich hatte mich
verirrt und er hat mir gesagt wo ich
nach hause kommen kann
aber das ist ja ungeheuer wichtig sie
sagen auch immer wieder sie verließen
deutschland mit heißem herzen und heine
im gepäck ich möchte eigentlich beides
von ihnen erläutert haben zuerst
vielleicht zu diesem haus im herzen wie
überwindet man einem solchen haus eine
solche enttäuschung einen solchen
schmerz weil immerhin sind ja
deutschland heute auch eng verbunden
ja aber das sei eine völlig neue
verbindung wenn ich so sagen darf
die sprache ist da das ganz richtig aber
die verbindung ist oder ich also von mir
von mir aus gesehen neu und der hass wie
überwindet man den hass ich kann nur das
sagen wir mal autobiografisch kurz
beschreiben
es war im jahr 1954 er weiß es zum
zweiten mal zurück in europa aber es mir
immer am herzen gelegen hat
an der damals hieß der freien
universität in berlin halten auch die eu
und das war zehn jahre nach dem versuch
eines attentats auf hitler den 20 juli
putsch und ich habe da reingeschmuggelt
verschiedenen gründen
der hauptredner ein sozialdemokrat
ehemalige oberpräsident von schlesien
also von breslau sozusagen waren
patienten freund meines vaters den
wollte ich sehen und habe mich
eigentlich rein geschubst sozusagen denn
die in dieser gedenkens gedächtnisfeier
am bendlerblock also an der stelle wo wo
auch einige unter unter einem ermordet
worden sind und einfach die erfahrung
und das sage ich jetzt mit gewissen
vertrauen denn ich habe am nächsten tag
sofort an meiner lehrer einen brief
geschrieben dessen kopie ich noch habe
also weiß ich dass ich das damals im
vorlauf gefasst habe der anblick auf die
witwen und die kinder war irgendwie hat
mich tatsächlich von ich würde sagen ja
schlagartig verändert von diesem haus
besagt ja ja ja oder sagen wir ja also
zumindestens von einem hass angefangen
zu befreien und das ging dann sehr
schnell muss ich sagen dann habe ich
mich wie gesagt mit der geschichte noch
vertraut gemacht und ja den hass
irgendwie glaube ich in einer art
verständnis um gewechselt so im leid
werden die auch alle ihnen die gleich im
leid werden dir alle irgendwie gleich ja
ja ja ich meine die vorwürfe sagen und
das ist sehr milde ausgedrückt die die
ungeheuren täuschung dass sich so viele
deutsche so
und und jubel gab also diese sache und
diesem schlechten regime ergeben haben
aber es gab eben auch ausnahmen und in
meiner arbeit inklusive in dem letzten
buch das ich mit meiner frau geschrieben
habe über die durch pon höhe von hans
von dohnanyi habe ich hauptsächlich mit
menschen beschäftigt die einen gewissen
anstand hatten und widerstand geleistet
und widerstand geleistet haben oder
zumindest das gibt ja dann verschiedene
stufen nicht mitgemacht haben sich fern
gehalten haben und dann auch einige sind
in den widerstand genommen aber
hauptsächlich haben fangen bei an damen
das irgendwie gesagt einen persönlichen
anstand bewahrt haben und sich anständig
benommen haben die meisten menschen um
es milde auswirken mitgelaufen sind also
der haus lässt sich verwandeln in
verständnis vielleicht den geteilten
leid eben wenn man sieht dass es
menschen gibt die widerstand geleistet
haben
was ist mit heine im gepäck sie haben
auch öfters mal gesagt keine ist ein
seelenverwandter von ihnen heinrich
heine
ich habe hier sein deutschland ein
wintermärchen ich muss gestehen ich weiß
das ist ein großer dichter ich habe viel
gelesen während des studiums das kann er
ist mir nie so richtig ans herz
gewachsen ich habe das gefühl ich habe
ihn nie richtig verstanden helfen sie
mir ja ich habe mich und einen
seelenverwandten
ich bin neben aufgewachsen so zu sagen
wir waren immer 334 in paris schon
erwähnte und da hat er angefangen mir
eine vorzulesen ganz besonderes ist
deutschland ein wintermärchen es sind
herrlich stellen drin und
und die die herrliche sprache auf der
einen seite und der sport gegenüber den
deutschen auf der anderen seite war
irgendwie befreien
da hat die wirklich zu gefühl das hat er
schon erkannt in den 18 und 20 20 jahren
und 34 jahren als den abriss ecke ins
exil ging irgendwie wie gesagt und dann
muss ich gestehen obwohl das
wahrscheinlich kein besonderes lob ist
dass seine eigene enthusiasmus für
napoleon sich für mich wie gesagt wird
ansteckend war und das war natürlich in
paris dann als ich sechs und sieben
jahre war sehr leicht sich mit napoleon
sozusagen auf ihn herauf zu blicken und
ich glaube das ist für kinder gar nicht
schlecht und aufrichtige personen wobei
ich dann natürlich auch wusste mit
heiner aber auch ohne eine also dass nur
folien dann schließlich auch ein
diktator wurde aber erst hatte man das
gefühl waren befreien das ist ja auch
tatsächlich so hat er wirklich
verschiedene fahrer ab sondern im leben
durchlebt ja sie haben ein neues buch
das demnächst erscheinen dir das heißt
in der fremde zuhause in der ferne
zuhause in der ferne entschuldigen sie
ja was heißt das zuhause in der ferne
erklären sie mir der tipp den titel das
kann ich ihnen
gesagt kann hier nicht leicht erklären
denn der täter kam er plötzlich das wort
heimat fällt mir sehr schwer
ich liebe es nicht warum nicht weil ich
die heimat wurde mir enteignet sagen wir
mal wenn als ich sechs jahre alt war
kann ich sagen dass ich gegenüber im
nazi-deutschland einheitsgefühl hatte
und ich bin viel glücklicher mit dem
amerikanischen englisch amerikanischen
ausdruck home zuhause ja zu hause das
das da bin ich auch zu hause in new york
in amerika in der ferne wie mir das
bekommen es kann ich ihn wirklich nicht
erklären das war plant plötzlich ein
fall dem ich sehr dankbar gegenüber bin
weil ich glaube es gar kein schlechter
titel in der ferne
fern von wo ich geboren bin fan von
europa das sie überlebte und immer noch
liebe aber zu hause wie gesagt sie sind
vielleicht zu hause nicht in ihrer
heimat genauer neben in ihrer in der
ferne
man ist ja ich meine ich mache einen
unterschied zwischen dem etwas
sentimental aus berkheim hat gerade in
deutschland fühle mich wie gesagt zwar
zu hause aber aber eben als ausweg um
den anderen
um das wort heimat zu vermeiden sie
haben am anfang des gesprächs erwähnt
das im moment nicht in new york sind sie
verbringen einige zeit jetzt im sommer
schon mehrere jahre in sils maria zwecke
jahrzehnts schuldige schon sehr sehr
lange
sie ist maria ist das auch ein stück
weit ein zuhause geworden sie absolut
absolut von einer wichtigkeit die ich
gar nicht
die kann nicht zu überbieten ist wie das
entstanden ist also sagen wir mal ich
weiß nicht ob sie es kennen ich meine
klar ja
das erste ist sozusagen die natur selbst
die ich zum ersten mal erfahren habe
meine vier jahren in silva planer bei
ferien in meinen eltern noch hatten
damals und dann bin ich sofort zurück
als wir als erste mal wieder in europa
war zum zum studium sozusagen also für
mehr forschung wollte ich nach selber
planen das heißt jetzt fahren
1950 aber das ist mir nicht gelungen ein
schwarzer sagte mir im zug das können
sie nicht das zu weit
wenn sie so wenig zeit war habe ich
verschoben bis 54 bin dann mit mit der
familie aufgefahren
und ja dass ich glaube ich habe schon
genug gesagt für mich war es sind ein
segen es ist kein ort es ein segen und
ich glaube es sozusagen über bestellt
wieso man man liebe dazu da ist die
natur da ist die sprache oder eine
sprache die ich sonst eigentlich nie
frei hatte in dem sinne wissen was ich
meine wenn natur sprache und mehr
freundschaften und das gefühl wie gesagt
ja ich habe mich angestrengt zu arbeiten
um nach hause zu kommen und sitzt habe
mich erholt um mehr zu arbeiten wird
wenn er mal sehen ist war und ist ein
sowohl herzensanliegen wie wir dann
haben wir vielleicht der schönheit von
sils alle diese schönen bücher zu
verdanken die sie geschrieben haben
ich habe etwas mitgebracht nämlich
basler läckerli schön bei mir gesagt
wurde dass das kekse sind die sie
unglaublich mögen aus der schweiz
das können und die auch so etwas wie zu
hause bedeuten für sie ja die habe ich
hier kennengelernt in der schweiz vor
vielen jahrzehnten lobby und dann jedes
mal aus der schweiz weg habe ich mir
einige mitgenommen und dann ergab sich
als meine kinder noch kinder waren was
sie weiß gott jetzt nicht mehr sind dass
ich wenn sie sich irgendwie weh getan
haben oder so etwas bin ich zu ihm
gerannt und gesagt hier ist sie mögen
sie kennen dich also notfalls can
notfalls kekse oder aber es war und ich
bin sehr stolz so zu sagen zu dürfen
dass sowohl mein sohn mir meine tochter
meine liebe zu sehen ist nicht nur
verstehen sondern in ihre eigene weise
nachfolgen nachziehen und das bezieht
sich dann auch auf die bahre leckerli da
haben wir so etwas kleines gemeinsam ich
bin den basen geboren und für mich waren
das war nicht wie möchten sie kann dies
aber es waren immer ein bisschen meine
meine zu hause cska hause ja
zu hause ja das kann ich gut verstehen
und mit basel habe ich für die
verschiedensten beziehungen durch jakob
fugger dem großen historiker aber auch
wenn ich ganz kurz erwähnen darf
es gab ein wunderbarer namens rudolf
nissen der haupt assistent wurden den
deutschen chirurgen saubere war dann
emigrierte er ist in die türkei dann
nach amerika und dann endlich bekam er
den ruf nach basel
und wo hat ein helles haus in riehen und
habe ihn dort oft besucht schon jetzt ja
auch die verbindung könnte man noch
machen mit nietzsche csu maria und basel
basel merklich aus hessen
das kann wie das passiert ist weiß ich
nicht natürlich eine ungeheuer wichtige
verbindung
ich habe angefangen mit den unzeitgemäße
betrachtungen betrachtungen und habe ihm
dann immer weiter gelesen und das war
also in 15 jahren da war dass die
meinung in amerika hauptsächlich nitsch
irgendwie ein vordenker vom
nationalsozialismus für mich war etwas
völlig anderes einer der tiefsten
psychologen dies überhaupt gab an ein
tief denkende überlege oder kritiker
seiner eigenen zeit und eigentlich
unserer zeit auch noch ungewisser sinne
und habe auch einiges über ihn
geschrieben und immer wieder betont dass
man ihnen wirklich verstehen muss das
wenn er auch möglich sich etwas etwas
stark ausgedrückt hat oder so dass er
eigentlich im grunde hoffte ist der
mensch ist sozusagen mein wissen selbst
überwinden würde
in dem sinne zum besten entwickeln würde
und also würde ich jetzt sagen wenn ich
das ganz kurz auf englisch wenn man das
gibt schöne ausdruck jetzt hab ich
vorher schon wieder vergessen angels of
the action so aber wie gesagt er hatte
die hoffnung dass das man dass ich
menschen ziehen könnten
und dann gibt es sich selber
hinauswachsen über selbst hinauswachsen
können und über gewisse elemente in
seiner eigenen zeit wie zum beispiel
antisemitismus war er 100-prozentig
stark dagegen waren kämpfe dagegen dass
er an auch andere sachen gesagt hat und
so weiß ich dann trotzdem würde ich
sagen
erst das ihr psychologe gerade auch für
die deutschen
und herr li sprach am meistens und ja
also ich schulde ihm viel
die sprache liegt ihnen am herzen das
merkt man schon bei heyne haben sie die
sprache gelegt gehen wir zurück zu heine
ja ich wollte gerne mit ihnen über
freiheit sprechen und von heine stammt
da dieses bild freiheit ist eine kerker
blume so ist ja warum ist freiheit eine
kerker blume weil es wenige menschen
gibt und sie sind eben eine ausnahme die
die freiheit und die sicherheit freiheit
und sicherheit anerkennen wenn sie es
genießen und das ganz anders wie man die
frische luft annimmt man glaubt einfach
dass das ist so das soll so sein und
dass freiheit ein gutes dass man erstens
erreichen muss also in der 1
das muss man in der gesellschaft an eine
sagen wir mal eine verfassung geben man
muss an ein rechtssystem aufbauen ist
ungeheuer schwierig sozusagen die
bedingungen für die frage zu schaffen
aber wenn sie weggenommen werden wenn
man dann plötzlich von pfeilen und
freiheit kommen dann also in einem
kerker geliefert wird dann merkt man was
man verlor ist das keine schöne blume
wäre ja ja sie sagen die freiheit ist
gegenwärtig bedroht ja auch in sicheren
staaten also jetzt nicht nur in den
staaten von denen aus jetzt flüchtlinge
zu uns kommen sondern auch in sicheren
staaten ist die freiheit bedroht was
petra roth in die freiheit
auf der einen seite es gab keine frage
dass die terroristen wie wir sie nennen
also sagen mal el kaida ist es und so
weiter dass die unsere freiheit bedrohen
und und möglichst die haben einen
wirklichen hast aber eine freie
gesellschaft
aber noch wichtiger noch viel wichtiger
sind strömungen in unseren eigenen
ländern die sich mehr von freiheit
entfernen um größere autorität und
sicherheit zu haben
da werden oft als populisten dargestellt
und das ist dann für sich nicht nicht
unrecht und unrichtig aber es ist eine
reine eine große gefahr dass man zum
teil also zum teil ist es so dass die
populisten wie ich sie nennen würde
meist rechts stehend aber nicht nur auch
links stellen auch diese ries an
griechenland wird zu leihen als
populistische strömungen absoluten
absoluten eines ganz richtig auch in der
geschichte gab es dann links aus
unterdrückung und und w aber jetzt wie
gesagt an einen hass auf das moderne auf
der modernen welt auf die freie säkulare
welt und zurück zum gewissen
fundamentalismus zurückzuhaben
autoritären denken und auf der anderen
seite ist es ist es mindestens amerika
so dass diese eine große welle ausgelöst
von der sogenannten tea party eigentlich
kein staat mit andern hass auf den staat
hat außer dass man dem staat das recht
gibt steuern einzuziehen um umverteilung
zu sorgen und wie also große ausgaben
für verteidigung aber sonst nicht gott
behüte man soll keinen sozialstaat ein
sozialstaat nein wirklich ein wirkliches
ressentiment gegen den sozialstaat gegen
den dass wir in welcher seite wo man
sich um die alten und armen kümmel
sie nehmen jetzt ein ressentiment ich
würde auch sprechen von einer
vertrauenskrise
wohin wurzelt diese vertrauenskrise
lassen sie mich das beschränken wirklich
im augenblick auf die usa weil ich das
am besten glaube ich über senkt dann und
auch da würde ich die unwahrheit dazu
dass man sich wahrscheinlich
unvermeidlich übertreibe oder banale
sachen sage aber in der märkte geht ist
tiefe vertrauenskrise sagen wir mal
einen zweiten quartals krise im
öffentlichen leben im stab in der
regierung in der kirche in institutionen
überhaupt und ich glaube an geht
wirklich zu weit zu sagen außer
möglichen vertrauen dass zamalek und
auch da ist beschränkt
in einer familie noch xt oder zwischen
zwei menschen
aber im ganzen in der gesellschaft als
solche ist vertrauen zu einem sehr
großen gerade verloren gegangen und das
ist für eine demokratie verheerend
sprechen wir gleich darüber was mit der
demokratie passiert aber zuerst will ich
so gerne noch besser verstehen was die
ursachen sind dafür also gerade sie als
historiker wenn sie so oft beschreiben
wie es war in der weimarer republik
dieses junge pflänzchen und dann diese
auch ein stückweit populistischen
strömungen die die jungen menschen
fasziniert haben mitgerissen haben was
kann man ja schlecht vergleichen aber
trotzdem was soll auch nicht aber was
was ich denn heute die vertrauenskrise
die sie als historiker wo sehen sie
gleich doch parallelen oder worin
besteht diese vertrauenskrise wurde
stellte ich er habe aber immer versucht
zu zeigen dass die alpen bindung die es
gegeben hat heute sehr viel schwächer
sind sind diese bindung sind viel viel
spreche dass innerhalb der kirche
innerhalb der gesellschaft und so war
innerhalb der bildung und so was meinen
sie mit bindungen erziehung sie meinen
hinein sozusagen die menschen sind nicht
mehr so sehr jetzt religiös erzogen zum
beispiel das mal nicht unter anderem ja
ich meine das und ich sage das mit mit
mit trauer aber ich glaube man kann
sagen dass in der welt eine welle von
verdummung um sich geld das alleine
schon sorgen macht und das überhaupt ich
mal dann kommen wir zurück auch nicht
nur in amerika sondern auch in europa
ein ein starkes gegen gefühl gegen
irgendwelche eliten besteht und
und wie gesagt man man man traut
niemandem mehr also niemand im
öffentlichen leben mehr und immer mehr
ein verdammter individualismus ich meine
ich bin in einer alten welt in einem
liberalen welt individualismus ist sehr
sehr zu schätzen
aber heute ist das abgewählte glaube ich
in gewissem sinne und viele leute in
zeit der globalisierung eine zeit wo
alles so kompliziert ist
kommt jemand hin und so weiter und
erzählt von wie einfach ein klick wie
einfach es ist der gute ihr basler jacob
burckhardt table simple pkt gesprochen
also die einfach die vereinfacher und
die vereinfachte haben heute glaube ich
sind sehr alamode sowohl in amerika wie
zum teil auch in europa das sagen der
wutbürger tja nach dem einfachen rezept
schreit ja er ist im moment weit
verbreitet wenn sie selber gebäude tja
und man könnte natürlich auch sagen wo
sind die menschen gingen noch eine
gewisse früher eine große autorität
hatten
wie sag mal ein goal oder ein jo-jo
unsere und dann kommen wir also zurück
nach amerika zu amerika würde ich sagen
das land ist im ist entwickelt sich zu
einer musikalischen oligarch und die
rolle des geldes da schon der große
französische historiker alexis de
tocqueville erkannt hat dass amerika wie
gesagt eine ganz besondere motiv
entwickelte beziehung zum geld hatte es
ist heute noch viel schlimmer und ich
glaube dass die europäer haben das schon
oft sich darüber lustig gemacht über
amerikaner mit dem dollar aber dass
die macht des geldes in klein in wenigen
händen und die macht die sie ausübt
durch die medien durch durch die
parteien ist erschreckend
und so jemand wenn ich das sagen darf
wie der herr donald trump ich glaube sie
haben ein analog dazu aber dass der
nicht dabei ich hingehen in der schweiz
aber es gibt analogen haben aber die
donald trump ist die verknüpfung von
dieser verdummung und von diesem drang
vereinfachung
jetzt haben sie vorhin alexis de
tocqueville erwähnen wir haben
philosophen aus dem neunzehnten
jahrhundert er hat ein buch geschrieben
über die demokratie in amerika das immer
wieder auch gelesen wurde wo man den
eindruck gehabt dass fehlentwicklungen
vorhergesehen richtig und dogville hat
diese demokratie unglaublich bewundert
er hat gleichzeitig aber immer gesagt es
gibt gefahren für die demokratie es kann
zum beispiel zur tyrannei der mehrheit
kommen ja eine tür nach einer dummen
mehrheit vielleicht einer verführte
mehrheit und zwar genau dann wenn einem
volk oder einer nation eine gemeinschaft
der anstand fehlt die schwierigkeit die
ich da sehr ist einfach wie kann eine
demokratie aus sich heraus diese idee
des anstands der tugenden der sitten
generieren wenn sie doch eigentlich
freiheits propagieren möchte ja das muss
ich ehrlich gestehen ist ist ungeheuer
kompliziert würde ich sagen
denn da kommen wir irgendwie auch auf
die jetzt auf die ganze frage der
erziehung von menschen auf die
kinderstube auf familienleben und so wo
wie und wo der anstand gepflegt wird ist
wie gesagt eine eine große
herausforderung
und da habe ich kein patentrezept oder
irgend sowas kann man sollte man sollte
eben den anstand mehr und mehr
anerkennen stattdessen bekommen wir
zumindest in amerika
im augenblick wirklich wie gesagt eine
bürokratie vorsichtig die die immer
weniger mit demokratie zu tun hat ich
meine dem kritik besteht wirklich nicht
nur auswählen
die wahl ist wichtig aber nicht alleine
nicht nicht nur sondern sich also aus
doch irgendwie eine sagen wir mal eine
gebildeten und münchen bürger bürger und
all das ist im augenblick im wanken
also geld regiert ein stück weit die usa
sagen sie wenn ihr jetzt auf die wahlen
noch schauen bereits in einem jahr wird
es soweit sein ungefähr einem in einem
jahr wenn ihre clinton gewählt würde
dann würde das heißen dass eigentlich
zwei familien während 30 jahren die usa
regiert haben mit einer pause von acht
jahren nämlich die amtszeit von barack
obama da frage ich mich wie kann es in
einer demokratie so weit kommen dass
eigentlich zwei familien aus der
monarchie oder eine abwechselnde
monarchie regieren das ist ja eine
demokratie eigentlich die usa wie kommt
dazu damit dann damit beginnen so sagen
kann sie angegangen sehr traurig sehr
traurig moment ja ich die vereinten
staaten im augenblick sind in einem
traurigen zustand und nicht nur genau
wie sie gesagt haben also die das fehlen
von wirklich politischen größen sagen
mal ob ich freue mich das wort führen zu
benutzen also als verständlichen gründen
aber menschen die ihm die verantwortung
übernehmen wollen und auch in der in der
öffentlichkeit ja so tun die
verantwortung zu übernehmen
aber das ganze durch total durch die
medien zum teil durch die indifferenz
der menschen selber der bürger und so
es ist die politik abgewertet so zu
sagen und dass das allgemeine der
allgemeine wohlstand oder allgemeine
frage wie wie soll eine gesellschaft
sich selber reformieren und so ist
beschränkt in amerika es gibt
selbstverständlich menschen die sich
darum kümmern und und auch das zum
ausdruck bringen wie wie das land sich
reformieren könnte aber im augenblick
kann ich nur sagen dass sie können sich
nicht vorstellen glaube ich wie wie sehr
das geld eine neue macht darstellt und
wie auch gerade unter dem in dem
amerikanischen populismus der leg neue
saison ist von etwas das schon oft
gegeben hat also die tea party ist
sozusagen nur ein neuer episoden ein
neuer auf von fundsachen geht es schon
früher gegeben hat aber ein vorläufer
der party glaubt ja bekannt ist mit
kräftig aber es gab noch verschiedene
andere bewegungen in amerika die dann
wieder sozusagen abebben
aber die ersten mal aufgekommen sind und
mit denen man die ähnlichkeiten haben
mit der tea party also auch einfach
einfach der ideologie großes gefahr
busse ansicht dass alles nur ein 1 1
wie soll ich sagen eine verschwörung
eine verschwörung also verschwörung
station gab es immer einen
amerikanischen geschichte oder sehr oft
sehen falls aber so wie es jetzt ist
dass solche wie soll ich sagen solche
ausnahmen zwar historisch kann man sagen
sie sind nicht
es gab vorläufer und trotzdem sind sie
nicht kann man sagen sie sind ausnahmen
oder sind was als neues und schwer und
gefährlich aber noch nie mit solchen
geld ausgestattet aber was ich noch
nicht verstehe ist die haben ja dafür
plädiert dass es so etwas wie am stand
bräuchte er wieder tugenden man könnte
auch von gemein sie entsprechen der
nötig wäre um die demokratie aus
eigentliche demokratie wieder zu stärken
gerade die tea party ist ja oft auch
nahe bei den religionen es gibt viele
auch republikaner die sehr religiös sind
im glauben ja aber sie würden ja schon
glaube ich von sicher behaupten dass sie
sehr orientiert sind dann wehrten
vielleicht am christlichen werten an
religiösen werten also offenbar ist die
orientierung an werten kein garant dafür
liberal oder demokratisch zu denken in
der weise wie sie es gerne hätten nicht
nur wie ich es gerne hätte sondern wie
ich glaube die die sogenannten founding
fathers überblick also die gründerväter
der amerikaner republik es wollten die
hatten ein hoch intelligenter und
wichtiges konzept dass ich kurz
sozusagen als sowohl liberal wie
konservativ bezeichnen würde und dann
wunderbares verständnis zum teil von
montes geld an anderen europäischen
denkens begnadigt aber aber hatten die
verfassungsrichter eine großartige an
großartige errungenschaft und jetzt habe
ich ehrlich gesagt dessen was ihre frage
war
mich hat interessiert inwiefern sie
sagen können es würde quasi genügen auf
anstand zu pochen auf werte zu pochen
gerade wenn wir bedenken dass die tea
party sehr oft mit religiösen
gruppierungen verbietet sich selber
religiöse werte auch zuschreibt stehen
gefahr an ein wort von ihnen dann mit
dem wort wegzurennen sozusagen
andere richtung und das ist jetzt
mehrmals über die religiöse seite
gesprochen haben das möchte ich ganz
kurz ansprechen die kirchen also die
kirchen euro in den usa sind auch und
verwandlung in diesen massen kirchen die
jetzt event the locals die jetzt wichtig
sind und noch viel wichtiger
gerade was die vereinten staaten anlangt
jetzt ist die tatsache dass viele von
den leuten und so gleichzeitig
fundamentalisten sind also ein land das
so stolz früher war oder zum großen teil
noch ist auf seine technischen
errungenschaften seine technologie seine
wissenschaft und sie an das anti
wissenschaftlichen das riesen das ist
auch die morgen dass ein wort das
nietzsche übrigens in die politik
eingebracht hat und richtig gefunden hat
wie wichtig das ist dass es ist kaum zu
glauben
und das ist sagen wir mal würde ich
sagen aber jetzt kommen wir etwas auf
ein anderes problem
ich wollte sagen uns konzentriert auf
die südstaaten er hatte auf die staaten
sich früher die in den bürgerkrieg in
amerika den 68er jahren sich für die
sklaverei erklärt haben und der graben
zwischen dem süden und dem norden ist
gewachsen im süden wie gesagt wenn sie
von religiös mit recht regen dann muss
ich sagen ja aber das religiöse ist sehr
nah an dem fundamentalismus
man darf über darwin man kann allenfalls
im süden sagen ja es gibt noch ein
anderer meinung wir glauben allerdings
dass das die welt in sechs tagen
errichtet worden ist und 7 tage und das
dass die anderen da die glauben als 1000
von jahre
ja das ist alles eine lüge
aber das ist ja gegen die bibel also ein
fundamentalistisches sie ja wenn die
kreationisten die sehr starken sind ja
ja ja und dass das für schultern auch
mit mit so eine art gefahr kommen wir
zurück auf ihr dasein als historiker sie
89 jahre alt zu überblicken viel viel
zeit ist ihrer meinung nach die welt
ganz grob gesprochen in dieser zeit
besser geworden oder schlechter ich bin
eigentlich jenseits von bösen jenseits
von guten durch sie ist nicht sie ist
nicht besser geworden
wenn man ich meine in manchen hinsicht
manchen gebieten ja also muss ich das
selbst so frau zu sagen was gesundheit
anlagen also in unseren in unserem
paradies so zu einem westlichen
prosperieren welt ist ist die gesundheit
der menschen besser geworden
ich glaube aber man kann sagen obwohl
das viele republikaner in meinem land
bestreiten würden dass der sozialstaat
schließlich einen gewissen an standen
die gesellschaft bringt halt dass man
den armen helfen kann
das ist etwas was aber auch teil einer
täglichen debatte in amerika ist wie
weit man armen menschen helfen soll
da ist eben ein völlig anderer
albinismus groß geworden sagt es und
gottes wenn du nicht den menschen helfen
die sollen sich selber hochkrempeln und
wenn es ist nicht können ist ihr eigener
schuld
da ist sehr viel noch zu tun weder
besser noch schlechter geworden also auf
müssen sie ich habe die welt als inter
oder den faschisten und dann also mehr
deswegen jetzt die gleichen zeit gesehen
da war die welt wirklich doch von terror
und einer dummheit und am verbot von
freiheit so überzogen dass das dass man
nur sagen kann
die überwindung davon es ist ein zeichen
dass die bettenwelt gebessert hat man
kann auch sagen ganz direkt auf die
bundesrepublik sehen dass die zweite
deutsche republik also dabei man erst
jetzt jede zweite sich sehr viel besser
entwickelt hat und ein kleinbus
erfolgsgeschichte ist worauf man im
westen stolz sein sollte überhaupt der
begriff des westens entschuldigen sie
wenn ich immer von etwas zu weit
schweifen
aber mir liegt der westen eben das was
man den westen genannt hat das abendland
mit seinen zivilisatorischen und dann
später mit seinen demokratischen sitten
und gebräuchen das war das war aber dass
sehr sehr wichtiges und ich muss ehrlich
gestehen ich rede gerne über den westen
wobei ich eine historische entwicklung
sehe wie sich sozusagen die die nationen
entwickelt haben zu einer zur
rechtsstaatlichen ordnung und zur
unterdrückung von terrorismus und so
weiter und so weiter aber
aber zu sagen dass ich die will
gebessert hat wenn man wenn man anfängt
mit dem bösesten was das gegeben hat ich
war nur in dem sinne ist sowohl hitler
wie es darin
ich werde die moderne welt die modernen
errungenschaften dazu benutzt haben um
die menschen zu unterdrücken weil man
daran fängt dann ist es leicht sozial
relativ leute sagen doch eine besserung
zu sein sagt auf jeden fall sind wir
freier geworden verpflichtet uns diese
freiheit sie sollte ohne irgendwelche
fragen sollte so sollte uns verpflichten
tut sie es das wird sich zeigen dass
kann
das kann wie gesagt sie sagen
freundlicherweise gesagt ich bin es
dauert ja der über die vergangenheit
zurückblicken kann ich kann aber nicht
ich bin keine steuergelder zukunft was
meinen sie denn sie haben die freiheit
sollte uns verpflichten wozu sollte sie
uns verpflichten schwere eigenen
verteidigung
das ist würde ich sagen das ist das
allererste sich gegen jegliche
extremistische bewegung irgendwie erst
mal sagen mal im gespräch verteidigt
dann in der diskussion verteidigt in der
öffentlichkeit verteidigt und dann hat
wenn wenn kriminelle elemente auftreten
wie es gedanklich der fall ist also
gerade auch in ostdeutschland in den
letzten tagen da muss man mit autorität
und dem rechtssystem umgehen und das
sind das ist für eine demokratie sehr
sehr schwer aber dass man verpflichtet
ist zu sehen
wir müssen das was wir haben verteidigen
selbst wenn die wie gesagt die die
angriffe auf die freiheit sowohl von
außen kommen wie von innen und ich wir
haben jetzt hauptsächlich von ihnen
gesprochen aber wir sind sicher der
selben meinung dass selbstständige
freitag von außen bedroht ist und diese
äußere bedrohung verschärft und hat in
amerika fischer
denn den wunsch für sicherheit der
wunsch für sicherheit wiederum dann
überwachung und all das was ich also
eine bedrohung der freiheit bezeichnen
würde
vielen dank fritz stern das nehme ich
aus ihr schlusswort vielen dank dass sie
hier waren dankeschön wird ihm die
freiheit ist man kann es nicht genug
betonen also ein hohes gut
einer der bereit ist für die freiheit
auch einen hohen preis zu zahlen ist der
russische schriftsteller viktor
jerofejew mein kollege juri steiner
trifft ihn am kommenden sonntag zum
gespräch über die creme über stalin und
über die ähnlichkeit russlands mit ihren
schön wenn sie wieder dabei sind bis
dahin eine gute woche
[Musik]